>> Female Presenter: I'm honored to introduce
John Merrow one of the most
influential education reporters in the nation.
John
Merrow began his career as an education reporter
for NPR
in 1974 with the weekly series Options in
Education.
He
served as a host of the Merrow Report, an
award winning
documentary series, and is currently as the
education correspondent for
PBS News Hour.
Merrow's report has taken him from the
community colleges to the kindergarten classrooms
to
front lines of teacher protests to policy
debates on
Capitol Hill.
His varied reporting has continued to be
at the forefront of education journalism.
John's book,
you all have a copy, The Influence of Teachers
was
released in February and was deemed eminently
valuable
and a 'must read' by our nation's top education
leaders.
John also maintains a weekly blog "Taking
Note" where he's become
welcome an eminent education voices on the
web.
To state
it simply, without John, the country would
not know much
about what's really happening in our schools.
So please join me
in welcoming John Merrow.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> John Merrow: Thank you very much.
It is a treat to be at Google.
Is this working?
Are you guys good here?
You want me to
speak up?
It's okay.
Yeah.
Thank you very
much.
Boy.
I wanted to talk about a couple of things.
Sort of a general theme.
What's wrong with this picture
when you think about American public education.
It was
Thoreau who said the mass of men lead lives
of quiet
desperation.
I think he was talking about high school
kids.
We have not figured out how to make high school
a
rewarding experience.
As a consequence we have 6,000 kids
leaving, voting with their feet every single
school day.
More than a million young people.
And oftentimes that's
a defensive and perfectly rational decision
because high
school is often humiliating for an awful lot
of young
people.
I don't want to just talk about the stuff
that's
going wrong.
I'd really like to talk about solutions
especially because Google and people like
the Google
people have it in their capacity to change,
to demand
school, changes in the way schools function.
And
actually the way I think about it is that
-- there are
some of you in this room over the age of 30
perhaps.
Maybe one or two.
But anyone over the age of 30 went to
school and there were essentially three justifications
for going to school.
And today, only one of those three
applies.
And I do write about it in the book.
But
quickly, when I went to school or even my
children went
to school, you had to go there because that's
where they
kept the knowledge.
It was in the books.
And the
encyclopedias.
Remember they were on the shelf?
It was
in the head of the teacher.
That doesn't apply anymore
thanks in large part to Google and the Internet.
It's
this constant 24/7 flood of information that
our children
are swimming in or perhaps drowning in.
But information
is not knowledge.
So you don't have to go to school
because the information is there.
So therefore, you need
a different kind of school.
You need a school which
helps kids sift through this information and
turn it into
knowledge.
Maybe even into wisdom.
So that you need a
school that helps young people separate wheat
from chaff.
And since we want them to choose the wheat,
that means
you need schools which are self-consciously
aware of
their duty to teach values.
Second reason that my kids or I,
was socialization.
So the Italian-American kid could
learn to get along with the Puerto Rican kid.
The boy
get along with the girl so on so forth.
There is an app
for that today.
A lot of them.
And our kids are
socializing like crazy.
They are going Google plus and
Facebook and Farmville and they are -- it's
pen pals on
steroids.
You probably don't know what pen pals are.
[laughter] So
you need a different kind of school.
Because that
14-year-old that your 14-year-old is socializing
with
might not in fact be 14.
Might in fact be a lot older.
Might have some nefarious motives.
So kids need to be
helped to understand that that stuff that
they're sending
is more permanent than a tattoo.
Just because young
people are digital natives does not make them
digital
citizens.
And there's a role for adults in that.
The
third justification for school, for then and
now, is
custodial care.
We need a place to send our kids because
we're going to work.
We want them to be safe.
But they
are not safe in a school which is only providing
custodial care.
If it is a school which doesn't
understand the technology and the new responsibility
for
adults.
If it's in a school that doesn't understand
that
it's no longer enough to be an answer factory.
Then that
becomes a dangerous place.
Because kids are smart.
They
are inventive.
They are restless and they will start
using this technology in harmful ways.
And there is a
lot of that going on.
It's called cyber-bullying.
So
one of the reasons I wrote this book is we
need a
different kind of school.
We need a different kind of
teacher.
And I -- there are a number of issues they'd
like to jump around if you don't mind.
Because there's a
lot wrong with this picture.
One is that, you know,
everything else has changed.
Schools have changed very
little.
Schools tend to use technology to control.
And
so as most of our schools are these answer
factories, kind
of regurgitation education.
And that turns kids into
consumers.
They are producing on demand.
But they're
really just consuming what you fed them and
giving it
back.
That's not what we want our young people to
be.
We want them to be producers.
As I say, you still need a
building.
You need a place for our kids to go.
But
there's no reason in God's green earth to
respect the
walls.
Yes, send them to a building, but don't respect
the walls.
Young people in the school here, in Mountain
View, should be, could be, and perhaps are
in some of the
schools connected to young people in other
places.
Working on projects, creating knowledge.
Forgive me, Amanda and Vanessa,
because you heard this example.
I spoke at the
Commonwealth Club last night and they were
in the audience.
But in my -- I live in -- now live in New
York having
just moved from Palo Alto about a year ago.
But looking
out the window of our apartment building,
I notice that
on each corner there is a large trash receptacle
and our
neighborhood is clean.
And I was working on a piece for
the News Hour.
We were filming up in the south Bronx and
I don't know why I noticed it, but on an intersection
there was just one garbage can.
I thought, "okay, well,
let's not think of them as garbage cans."
And the
streets were dirty.
So don't think of these as garbage
cans.
I renamed them 'cleanliness opportunities'.
So my
neighborhood had four cleanliness opportunities.
I
thought, what a terrific project.
Tell the eighth graders to get their smart
phones and go to their corner
and take the pictures.
And then, the teachers -- those
eighth grade teachers -- in all the middle
schools in New
York City to do the same thing.
And then figure out a
way to share that data.
And do some data analysis and do
some thinking about it and some writing about
it and
maybe get in touch with a mayor.
You're creating
knowledge.
You're creating trouble.
But kids like to do
that.
It's positive stuff.
You can do it at school, too.
You get a little air quality monitor which
doesn't cost
very much and you go monitor the air quality.
You don't
want to take a field trip or can't take a
field trip.
Go walk
outside the build . But do it at 9 in the
morning or 11 and so on and
so forth.
Share that data; maybe you'll find some
anomalies.
I looked it up the other day, Texas has about
4,000
miles of fast-running water.
Fast-running.
It's not
that sluggish stuff at the border.
Why not have the
science classes in high schools go to the
water?
Sample
the water.
Acidity.
Alkalinity.
Speed, Color, Detritus.
Share
the data.
And where you find anomalies, gee, the water
gets much more acidic down here.
Let's find out why.
That's a reason to go to school, because you
are creating
knowledge.
And that's the challenge.
It's -- the
imperative, I would say.
High school is boring.
And it
is not producing the kind of young people
we need to fuel
the economy to keep the country moving.
I know Sandra
Day O'Connor spoke here recently and talked
about civic illiteracy.
Doug was telling me that.
Well, you
have illiteracy on all the fringes because
we are
focusing so deeply and so intensely on basic
literacy and
numeracy.
There are least three literacies that are
essential.
Basic literacy.
Numeracy and creativity.
But we're so focused on the first two, we're
driving out
the third.
I feel passionate about this because I don't
think we're moving in the right direction.
I think we
have this collision course maybe just ships
passing in
the night.
People understand what young people need or
even what the economy needs and yet they're
having this
imperative to get test scores up.
And so, the narrowing
of a curriculum continues.
Even though we moan and groan
about it, we're still cutting art, music,
Phys Ed, even
science.
And there's this pressure to say, "well, if
we
get these test scores up", and so, some of
these test
people are saying well, let's just test in
more subjects.
We tested in science.
We tested in music then we'd have
to have music as a, which is.
So what you have
now.
Let me use Florida as an example since it's
well-known for its evaluation system developed
under
former governor Jeb Bush, who is a genuine
intellectual
and a deep thinker about public education.
And on his
watch and even before they set up something
called FCAT
Florida Comprehensive Assessment Test.
The state of
Florida spends 10,900, call it 11,000 dollars
a year per pupil.
The FCAT
costs 20 bucks.
So they are using a 20 dollar
instrument to measure the use, the efficacy
of their
11,000 dollar investment.
That's fundamentally insane.
And I think of my own car.
I drive a used Toyota
4runner.
I think it's a 2002 which cost me 12,000
dollars.
And I spend 500 dollars a year evaluating
it.
The equivalent of the FCAT.
So I spend 500 for my
12,000 dollar investment.
Florida spends 20 bucks for
its 11,000 dollar investment.
You do the math.
And by
the way, my evaluation of my car takes one
day.
365 days
a year, it takes one day.
Florida kids go to school
180 days.
I have met teachers in Florida who say they
spend between one-fifth and one-sixth of their
time on that
FCAT.
Essentially one day a week out of five day
week.
Or one day out of every six days.
Either prepping for
the FCAT, talking about the FCAT, practicing
the FCAT
or giving the FCAT.
So it's not just that they don't
spend money on the evaluation of it.
They spend a lot of
time.
Time is opportunity.
Those days are gone.
You
spend them drilling.
You aren't going to spend them
doing the other things that you could be doing
in school.
And
what then?
Then they take the scores on this cheap test
and use it to make judgments about kids and,
of course now,
increasingly about teachers.
It is in a sort of,
you know when I say what's wrong with this
picture,
there's the, that's a major piece of what's
wrong with
th3 picture.
But, and the situation is has a potential
for getting worse because of a digital divide.
A growing
number of young people do not have access
to high
speed, to bandwidth.
Even if they have the
connections, the toys, they don't necessarily
have the
speed of connection.
But access is nowhere near enough
because the mind set has to be production.
The mind set
has to be schools that say -- and educators
who ask a
fundamental question -- schools say, "how
intelligent are
you?
How intelligent are you?
Let's compare."
That's not what we want.
We want
schools to say, "How are you intelligent?
How are you
intelligent?
How are you intelligent?"
Figure that out
and create opportunities to maximize that
growth.
Kids
are smart.
And I said before if they're in schools which
are just doing regurgitation education they
are probably
going to use that education in bad ways -- often
in bad
ways.
If the imperative of education is numeracy,
literacy and creativity, then schools should
be saying,
"how are you creative?
How are you creative?
How are
you creative?"
And figuring out ways to build that.
There are all these wonderful possibilities
that we need to, we need
to demand it actually.
How many of you have children in
school?
Okay.
So this is probably not, well it's slightly
skewed because there are many young people.
But in fact,
in the country only about 20 percent of households
have
school age children.
So there's an 80 percent who do not
have a immediate direct interest in public
education.
Now you start putting in grandchildren, the
numbers
change a little bit.
There's still a huge number of
people who do not have a direct immediate
interest in
what's happening in public school.
So part of what the
school people need to do is figure out how
to connect
with that 80 percent.
And part of the way you connect
with that 80 percent is when the kids become
producers of
knowledge.
When the work they do reaches that 80
percent.
I'm recruiting teachers now to probably
middle school or high school kids to go out
in a team and
just in their own neighborhood, go into stores
-- the deli
can be the doorman of the building, the gas
station guy,
the mechanic, somebody at Google -- and of
course frame
it shoot their own video.
Frame it the same way each
time and ask the person to recite a couple
of lines from
a poem.
And you want the 80 percent.
You don't want --
you got a kid in school -- you're disqualified.
You want someone
who doesn't have a kid in school and you create
a montage
of him saying "to be or not to be that is
the question.
Whether it is noble in the mind's eye" and
so on.
You stitch it
together and you put it up on YouTube and
those 12 people
who don't have kids in school then say, "hey,
do you see
what they're doing in school?
By the way, did you see
me?"
So you are going to build an audience.
It's a drip,
drip, drip thing.
But suppose in every community, four or
five teachers did that in different parts
of the town.
You'd have people saying, "wow."
And of course, the kids
would be learning.
They'd be creating something.
The
kids would be learning a real set of skills.
It's not
easy to get people to relax and look into
the camera and
say the lines and so, it's a whole set.
Then, of course,
you have to do the editing.
So there's a whole set of
skills for the kid.
And there is the thrill of
production.
There is the ownership.
You know Marx had
it right about folks being separated from
the fruits of
their labor.
Very few people get to do what Amanda and
I
do which is start something here and go all
the way
through to the end.
That's the opportunity that we want
our kids, - we should want our kids to have.
It's why
they thrive in extracurricular stuff.
Because they own
it.
So let me say, defining the problem.
Now, this
general heading is what's wrong with this
picture.
The
big thing that's wrong with the picture is
how we define
the problem.
When we talk about public education.
You
know, I would say that it's not that we have
aimed too
high and failed.
We've aimed too low and we have
succeeded.
You know, we simply do not ask enough of our
young people.
And we don't ask the right kinds of stuff.
Educators talk about rigor.
We need more rigorous
education.
Nobody has ever looked that word up
apparently.
You know that rigor mortis -- connect the
dots.
Rigor means harsh, yielding, painful.
And that's an
adult mindset about what education supposed
to be.
It's
wrong.
It should say challenging.
But you can't even get them,
break them of that habit which unfortunately
is very
revealing.
As I say we've aim too low and we've succeeded.
The second huge 'what's wrong with this picture'
is the
achievement gap.
Somebody define the achievement gap for
me?
Go ahead.
What's the achievement gap?
>> Male #1: [inaudible]
>> Who's the gap between?
>>Female #1: The rich and the poor
>> John Merrow: Rich and poor?
Actually not
usually.
I'm sorry?
>>Female #2: [inaudible]
>> John Merrow: Yes, it's in terms of race.
It's in terms of white
kids versus black kids or black and Hispanic
kids.
I'm
not sure if it occurs to anyone that that
in itself could
be something of a racist construct.
If we could only get
these kids who aren't white to do as well
as the whites do [chuckles wryly].
And I kind of think of that -- because so
my way of
playing with that idea -- but often what we
do is we have
an achievement gap between white kids and
nonwhite kids.
If we could just get these kids --. So the
focus in school
is often on the test scores which is the output.
There's
not much conversation about a couple of other
gaps.
The
gap in opportunity.
Gap in expectations.
Sometimes a
gap in leadership.
But if you have at least two of those
three, often you'll have an outcome gap.
But if you
only focus on the outcomes, then you end up
drilling those
kids.
There's a well-known vocabulary gap when young
people start preschool or kindergarten.
Number of words
is -- people argue about whether it's 3 million
or 30
million more words that the middle class or
upper middle
class white kid has heard than the poor kid.
But if
you're only focusing on the vocabulary gap,
what will
happen in poor schools is they'll start drilling
kids on
vocabulary.
Well, that's not how those white kids learn
those words.
They learned them in conversations.
They
learned by using words in social and family
kinds of but
schools where they're focused just on the
outcome, which
is what's going to be tested, they subvert
the process
and make it painful.
I often say that what we really
should talk about is the Asian/white achievement
gap.
You say, "My God will you look at this Asian/white
achievement gap."
We got to do something.
These white
kids are way behind.
We got to start drilling the white
kids.
Let's eliminate recess for the white kids.
Let's
get rid of art and music for the white kids.
I hope that
would suggest the absurdity of it.
That would be one of
the ways of thinking about what we need to
do in public
education.
I'm making it sound very bleak.
And I don't
mean to.
I actually like to show you a little clip
of
what we're working on now.
Part of our problem is an
absorption, a fascination with magic bullets.
Silver
bullets.
This will do it.
If we just could bring in
Teach for America, everything would be fine.
If we just
could have charter schools or vouchers or
some one
thing.
The New Orleans in August 2005 was virtually
destroyed by hurricane Katrina and the subsequent
flooding when the levees broke.
The school system had been --. We
started reporting from there not long after
that and, in
fact, just finished filming in November.
In October,
maybe.
So really six years.
We have six years worth of video
that we're now editing into a documentary
film, we hope, if
we get lucky and raise enough money to finish
it that
way.
And it's a remarkable story.
And with your
permission, I'll show you a little bit.
[drum beat] [helicopter noise]
[slow brass jazz music] In the fall of 2005,
six weeks after
Hurricane Katrina made landfall I arrived
in New
Orleans.
I think I saw it in the paper God answered
my
prayers.
>>Jimmy Fahrenholtz: Yeah, I'm not a particularly
religious person.
That's just
one of my asides.
God didn't answer my prayers.
I think that
we got lucky.
>>John Merrow: We got lucky.
>> Jimmy Fahrenholtz: Yeah
>> John Merrow: I was in New Orleans to report
on the city's
beleaguered public school system for the PBS
News Hour.
All but a handful of the schools sustained
incredible
damage.
60,000 students were displaced; many homeless.
Their teachers scattered across the nation.
And in the
midst of this great tragedy an unexpected
sentiment had
emerged.
>> Jimmy Fahrenholtz: The storm has come through
and done the
damage.
Look at what we can take from that, what we
can use it for.
It's a tool.
[construction noises]
>> John Merrow: For those who have been championing
drastic reform,
the opportunity was irresistible.
Hurricane Katrina had
shut down the city of New Orleans and with
it, its schools,
long considered among the worst in the nation.
The greatest
experiment in the history of American public
education
was about to begin.
>> [slow music finale].
[pause]
>> [upbeat jazz music].
[traffic noises]
>> Principal Laurie: It's powerful.
I feel so honored.
It's just an honor,
to be here at this point in time, to be part
of this new
beginnings.
[traffic noises]
>> John Merrow: December 14, 2005.
Much of the city is still
deserted.
In less than 24 hours, public school will
re-open.
No one is sure how many students to expect.
Here at O. Perry Walker High School, the pressure
is on.
Hopefully never ever again in the history
of this country, not mention the world,
will any group of folks be given an opportunity
because
of a Katrina or some other natural disaster.
But the
reality is we have this opportunity and we
need to seize
this moment.
>> Female teacher: We have to be on our toes
when the kids come in.
And
you set the stage.
We all know that from teaching.
If
you've taught one month, you know the first
day sets the
stage.
>>Male teacher #1: Some of us as teachers
we're going to want to go back
the way it was done before.
A lot of the children are going
to be expecting things to look like they did
before.
And
it's just going to be interesting how we can
create a new
vision of what -- who we are and what we want
to be.
>>John Merrow: Business as usual was out the
door.
Walker was
re-opening as a public charter school.
It would be
independent of the local school board for
four years.
If
it didn't prove its worth during that time,
it would
close.
>> Male teacher #2: We were slaves to the
old system, [coworkers agree] but the shackles
have been removed from us so now we are free.
We are
free to do the things that we need to do as
teachers to
educate.
I feel free.
[laughter].
[water sounds].
>> John Merrow: The raging river whose waters
destroyed New Orleans
begins here, 1400 miles away in northern Minnesota.
And
it's here at the Mississippi river's source
that charter
schools which would play a vital part in the
rebirth of
New Orleans were born.
It was at a meeting in 1988.
The
driving force was labor union leader Albert
Shanker.
>> Albert Shanker: I believe very strongly
that what you need to do is
give the professionals and the school the
right to run
the schools.
Stop telling them what to do.
>> John Merrow: What Shanker was proposing
was unheard of.
Most of
the country's 100,000 public schools were
run from
central offices, top down.
Shanker wanted to give control
to teachers and to principals who rarely got
to decide whom
to hire or fire or how to spend the money.
>> Shanker: Set the goals for them and tell
them what you're going
to measure five years from now and at the
end of that period of
time there ought to be real rewards and real
punishments
or real consequences for making it or not
making it.
>> Female teacher #2: Look up here.
>> John Merrow: Shanker and others hope that
every school district
would create at least one charter school as
a laboratory
for other schools to learn from.
But the idea of giving
power to individual schools was vigorously
opposed by
school boards.
Many states passed laws banning charter
schools or limiting their numbers.
By 2004, the
country's 15,000 school districts had opened
only 3,000
charter schools.
Charter schools were marginal at best.
Then came Katrina.
>> Leslie Jacobs: I went into the city in
October and you felt like you
were in a Hitchcock movie.
It was like a smart bomb had
gone off.
It was buildings.
There were no people; there were no birds;
there were no animals.
There were no signs of movement.
Schools
are shuttered.
The city is shuttered.
I think there was
the strong belief, at that point in time,
that with the
schools shuttered and the opportunity to start
it over
again, we were going to take advantage of
that and do a
much better job.
>>Leslie Jacobs: [voice over piano music]
Everyone in New Orleans wants the same things
-- safe
streets, good jobs, better schools.
>> John Merrow: Insurance executive and recent
mayoral candidate, Leslie Jacobs,
served on the Orleans Parish school board
for four years.
>> Leslie Jacobs: It's probably the most frustrating
experience I ever had in
my lifetime.
I work 30, 40 hours a week, every week, not
paid.
I
accomplished nothing.
[band music plays] The valedictorian of one
of our
high schools could not walk across the stage
and get her
diploma because she failed the graduation
exit exam in
math seven times.
>> Aesha Rasheed: It was kind of this poisonous
environment, I felt.
There was a very toxic environment in education
in New
Orleans before Katrina.
>>John Merrow: At the time was the education
reporter for the
Times-Picayune.
>> Aesha Rasheed: I think that there were
many good teachers but when
you're constantly labeled as failing and you
aren't supposed
to be failing, I think the adults start to
carry that
feeling of failure, too.
>> John Merrow: The problems weren't just
academic and in the district's
central office, corruption was rampant.
24 school
employees had been indicted on fraud charges.
71 million
federal dollars were unaccounted for.
New Orleans'
public schools were on the verge of bankruptcy.
>> Aesha Rasheed: I remember thinking like
how were you going to
resolve this depth of corruption, this depth
of
disenfranchisement, these deep feelings of
inadequacy?
How do you resolve that in a system that has
to keep
going?
And so, I used to think that if there could
be
just a few months where there was just no
school, right?
Then
Katrina happens, right?
And you're kinda like, "well, there you go."
>> John Merrow: In November 2005, with most
New Orleanians still
displaced, lawmakers in Baton Rouge took action.
[muted jazz trumpet music]
>>Female broadcaster: The house and senate
voted late yesterday to approve Louisiana
governor,
Kathleen Blanco's, proposal for the state
to take over schools in New Orleans.
[jazz harmonica music]
>> John Merrow: In an unprecedented move,
the state seized control of
100 of New Orleans' worst schools; 90 percent
of the
entire district.
Their challenge was immense.
>>John Merrow: Some people have said, "Well,
Katrina was in some way a
blessing".
>>Principal John Hiser: Let me tell you something.
If you looked into the
eyes of children who have been through that,
they would
never say that.
>>Principal Hiser: And what is your name,
sir?
.>> Male student: Kelvin Dawkins
>>Principal Hiser: Dawkins, is that correct?
>> Principal Hiser: Kids don't say that.
>> Principal Hiser: Anybody who works with
children knows damn well
Katrina was not a blessing in any way shape,
form, or fashion.
[children chatting] I have listened to all
of it:
"I left my teddy bear behind.
I left my room behind, my
games behind, my friends behind, my grandma
behind".
>> John Merrow: In spite of the obstacles,
the ambitious plan was for
the state to fix the schools.
Leslie Jacobs was
skeptical.
>> Leslie Jacobs: I'm still not convinced
today that a Department of Ed has
the capacity to run schools.
That's really not what
state Department of Eds are set up to do.
>> John Merrow: But Jacobs, then on the state
Board of Education, did
not want the local school board to run the
show, either.
She saw a way to take care of both problems,
give the
power to the schools.
>> Leslie Jacobs: I do not believe charter
schools are a silver bullet, period.
But if
you're a good school leader and you have the
freedom of a
charter school, you're going to run a good
to great
school.
>>John Merrow: In New Orleans, charter schools
were not going to be
competing with the traditional public school
system.
The
goal was for them to replace that system.
[children talking] As students
returned to old O. Perry Walker for the first
day of class
since Katrina, Principal Laurie made sure
they understood
this was the start of something new.
>> Principal Laurie: You guys know that we're
now a charter school versus New Orleans Public
School; you know that, right?
What that means is that we're no longer under
the
governor's structure of New Orleans Public
Schools.
This is now the Algiers Charter School Association.
And so, what
they did--.
>> John Merrow: Six years later New Orleans
is still rebuilding.
The
school system that once had 60,000 students
is now a
system of schools.
75 percent of them charter schools
with 40,000 students.
Academic performance has improved
every year.
Transforming the Big Easy has been anything
but.
>> John Merrow: That's the rough first ten
minutes of the film that
we're working on now.
It's a remarkable story.
It's a
story of what's possible.
They're still test-score driven.
I don't think they're asking that question,
'how
are you intelligent?'
But they're getting there.
And
it's a story of what's possible and, by golly,
it's a
story, California needs to watch, needs to
be aware of
because this is an incredibly -- fill in your
own
adjective state -- when it comes to public
education.
I
did a documentary in 2005, a history of public
education
in California, called First to Worst.
Sad to say, we could
do a sequel if there were another word that's
more
superlative than worst.
[chuckles wryly] "First to Worst to Even Worse'.
The rich/poor gap has grown.
The funding is still pretty screwed
up with about 400 of the state's 1000 school
districts
having private foundations that create a kind
of quasi
public/private system.
But our hope is that film.
Have any of you seen a film called Waiting
for Superman?
My hope
is that we'll undo some of the damage that,
that -- what
to me was a propaganda -- well made propaganda
film --
will undo some of that damage.
We're working a second
documentary, in addition to our work for PBS,
about a woman
named Michelle Rhee who was the chancellor
in -- people
are nodding their heads.
She's halftime in California
now.
She's married to the mayor of Sacramento.
But she
was chancellor in Washington, D.C. for three
years plus.
And we followed her on the News Hour.
If you saw her in
"Waiting for Superman", there's a scene where
she fires somebody.
That was our
footage.
We had a bit of legal squabble with the producer
for Waiting for
Superman about that.
Basically they wanted to use it
without paying for it.
And we had to threaten to sue and
they caved when I threatened to boycott the
Hollywood
premier in my underwear.
[laughter] They wrote us a big check at
that point.
But it wasn't much fun.
But anyway, there's
a documentary about Michelle Rhee that's coming
as well.
Let me see if there's is anything you would
like to ask or
say.
And I'm not -- I guess you want the microphone.
So
maybe would you say your name and --.
>> Male #2: I'm Harvey [inaudible] and near
the end of that clip it said that almost all
or
75 percent of the schools were run by private
foundations.
Is that --.
>> John Merrow: They're charter schools.
They're run by charter
operators.
They're not for-profit though.
[audience member responds inaudibly] They're
actually are no for-profit charter schools
there.
There's one that has a connection to a for-profit
operator.
But what New Orleans did -- because you've
seen the research about charter schools and
you know that
a lot of them are no better than regular public
schools--,
they are public schools.
But what New Orleans did, even
though it was desperate to open schools, it
turned down
most of the people who asked for a charter.
Who applied
for a charter.
They had about 50 applicants.
They
probably needed 20 schools.
They only approved six
charters and by setting that bar very high
at the
beginning, that didn't guarantee outcomes,
but it
certainly made it much more likely that they
would be
successful.
Yeah, please.
>>Female #3: Hi.
I'm Devon.
And I have two questions.
What do
you think the barriers are.
I perceive one as being the
fact that a lot of the teachers aren't prepared
to
utilize the media, all the technology that
we have available
right now.
And also, what do you think about testing?
Do you think it's possible to create the tests
that would
allow us to teach the way we'd like to?
Or do you think
those need to be generated?
>> John Merrow: Those are two terrific questions.
Let me take the
second one first about testing.
The answer is yes.
There
are good tests.
There's a program called the
International Baccalaureate which has a challenging
curriculum and tests that are built to test
that curriculum.
The flaw is that we use
cheap tests.
The company named Harts which makes flea
powder and kitty litter spends more money
testing its
products than we spend testing what our children
have
learned.
I mean that Florida example is probably not
an
outlier.
20 bucks on an 11,000 dollar investment.
But
sure you can have good tests.
We are in the process now
of developing national tests.
There's something called a
Common Core Curriculum.
And there are people trying to
develop tests.
My feeling, and by the way they're
having trouble finding the psychometricians
because they're all working
for Harts.
Or Toyota or somewhere else where they take
testing the products very carefully.
My hunch is that you could develop, for
example, an exam in physics and you wouldn't
have to
develop a new one each year if you said, "these
are the
five aspects of physics and you get -- here
are 100 good
questions in this aspect".
And just change the numbers.
So you can't teach each of the problems.
Release the whole test.
Release all 3,000 items and say the national
physics test
this year is going to be 30 of these questions.
Nobody's
going to.
And you just change the numbers.
I mean, you
could do something like that.
So you wouldn't have to
spend a ton of money developing new tests
every year and
you could have really good tests.
Barriers to using the
technology.
There are several.
I don't think, everyone
talks about teachers and their technological
illiteracy
or their fear and I think those are real.
I think a
larger barrier is the adult need for control.
And you
know they've gone through.
You all probably know more
about this than I do, I'm sure you know more
about this than I do, the notion of a walled
garden to
keep kids from going off and looking at porn
or whatever.
And those are -- there are some challenges
there.
My
wife was head of a girls school in Palo Alto
for many
years and she would not allow laptops because
she felt
that when you put this guy up, you're creating
a barrier.
And she was actually, Steve Jobs was one of
the parents,
and said to him, "when there's a tablet, we're
okay with
it."
And if you ever been in a college classroom,
been
in the back of the room while somebody is
up front
lecturing and everybody has their laptops
open, they're
doing all kinds of stuff.
But the barrier, yes, teachers
need some help.
But of course they can get the help from
the kids.
The kids are these digital natives.
If they
can let go.
But a larger part is that schools tend to
use the technology for control, to get information.
Instead of this idea of creating.
And so, you have to
change the mind set which says, "yeah, we're
going to be
in the building, but we're not going to respect
the
walls."
We're going to do real projects that are real
work.
The idea of using technology as a better way
of
getting kids to regurgitate is profoundly
offensive.
I
mean, there was a piece in the Times about
how some
school they were using the clickers to give
true/false
questions.
[laughs] I mean, that's technology -- they've
invested money to
buy these things it's insane.
But it's a combination of I
think ignorance and fear on the part of the
adults.
Yes,
sir?
>> Male #3: I'm Hubert Chang, software engineer
here and graduate of the
International Baccalaureate program.
So I'm wondering.
There's a book called Freakonomics and another
book
called SuperFreakonomics in which the author
is talking
about education, I think.
So I'm wondering whether you've read it
and what you think about it.
Specifically they gave two
points.
One point is that the achievement gap may
not so
much be the result of going to good schools
versus bad
schools but it may be the attitude of the
children's
parents.
Like in black communities, doing well in school
is sort of considered to be acting white.
>> John Merrow: Acting white yeah.
>>Male #3: Like there are negative consequences
of that for those
children.
And secondly they also make a point because
of
the feminine movement, right now compared
to let's say 40
years ago let's say the IQ and the quality
of teachers
have decreased a lot because it used to be
that a lot of
smart women were teachers and now they're
taking other
jobs leaving less smart people to become teachers.
>> John Merrow: There are two sort of complicated
thoughts.
So I
can -- I may have to ask you to remind me
the first one
again.
But on the notion of the teaching force.
There's
no question that the composition of the classroom
has
changed.
It used to be that there were very few jobs
for
talented women other than teaching and a few
others.
And
so, schools were filled with capable, smart
and so on.
And we had a system then where we trusted
the teacher.
Go to your parents.
My mom saved all my report cards --
bless her heart.
[laughter] And when I was an adult, gave me
the
report cards.
And by then I had children of my own.
And
I was -- and of course I looked at them which
was a huge
mistake.
But one thing I noticed was that in my
elementary school report cards, there was
a block about
this big for the teacher to write comments.
Johnny's
doing such and such -- he's running with scissors
-- whatever.
Then with my children.
My older son who's now 43.
It
was smaller.
By the time his -- my youngest -- there was
virtually no.
There was couple of check places where
they'd say does this or that.
What I inferred from that
is we were moving from a system of trust to
a place where
we really didn't care what the teacher said.
Because we
didn't trust the teacher.
And now, we're all about
verifying.
We're going to measure how you do on the
test.
And then we're going to draw some conclusions
about your teacher.
So we
move from trust to verify.
And it was Ronald Reagan who
said.
when talking about the Soviet Union , trust
but
verify.
And that's really what you need in education.
You need a system which trusts teachers.
We have this
big argument going on in this country defining
the
problem.
Is the problem we don't have enough good people
in the classroom teaching our children?
Or is the
problem that it's a crummy job?
If you're a teacher, you
cannot get up and say, "I need to use the
bathroom."
You
just can't do it.
I mean, you can't make a phone call.
You don't get to spend time with your colleagues.
You
don't have a 20 percent rule or anything approaching
that.
American teachers spend more time in front
of
their children than do teachers in countries
that are
eating us for lunch like Finland and South
Korea.
Their
teachers are expected to be able to watch
each other and
collaborate and talk about kids.
How's Charlie doing in
your class?
So there's a respect for the profession.
So
the argument is do we need better people?
Or do we have to
make it a better job.
The better people are, you know,
Teach for America.
Waiting for Superman.
If we could
just get rid of those bottom 10 percent.
And next year
there will be a new bottom 10 percent.
[chuckles wryly] The 'better job'
people say, "no you need to change the working
conditions."
Pay is a problem.
Teacher pay has not
moved very much in 40 years.
40 years ago the average
teacher made about 49,000 dollars, adjusted
for inflation.
Today it's 55,000
dollars.
That's a raise of 140 dollars a year.
I did
percentages but I've forgotten them.
140 dollars a year every year for 40 years.
But it's not the pay that teachers talk about
when
they're polled.
They want a chance to collaborate.
To
do what we do in our work.
We don't allow that to
happen.
So my hunch is -- and it's the argument of
this
book.
It's a big argument but it's irrelevant to
the
needs of kids.
Adults sparring is irrelevant, because as
I said at the beginning, the conditions have
changed for
kids in terms of school.
But if you made it a better
job, you would by definition -- it would be
more
appealing.
As you may know 40 percent of first year
teachers leave the profession in five years.
It's a huge
drain.
And the human capital costs to bring in new
people are huge as well.
It's not a rewarding profession
in the sense you have to teach for 20 years
before you
start having some real investment.
People are saying,
"no, you should pay new teachers more at the
beginning.
Forget these pensions.
Do an IRA.
Give them some
responsibility there and you can change that
structure
and bring in different people."
But that would be a
necessary condition but not a sufficient condition.
Acting white.
And the family.
I'm probably an outlier
on this.
Because I think educators -- the education
profession-- has an arrogance about it that
is entirely
undeserved.
And that is their attitude implicit hardly
ever stated is just leave your kids at the
door.
Leave
the money.
Leave your kids at the door and we'll educate
them.
And that ain't the way it works.
The parents are
the principal educators of the child.
Whatever else
happens.
Child's going to learn more from you as his
mother or father than from a teacher.
And so, schools
should capitalize on that, in my view, in
an organic way.
And if I were the school superintendent, which
I never
will be and I once was -- it's a long story.
I would say
in first grade, in kindergarten, the teacher
should say
once a week to the class have an assignment
which the
parents are a part of.
Kindergarten, go home and ask your mom or
your
dad your grandmother or guardian what was
the first movie
they remember seeing and come tell the class
about it.
Go shopping and get the price of this and
that soup and
crackers and come tell.
Ask your mom about the first
trip she ever took.
And you're in second grade now and
so write a little paragraph about it.
Interview your dad
about the first movie he ever saw.
His favorite food.
Any ordinary humdrum stuff.
You know the parent is going
to want to read what her child wrote.
And is going to to
want to read what the teacher said about.
And so, it
becomes--.
It's not that parent involvement committees
that schools set up.
It's just in the thing.
In the
fabric.
And then, you don't get this distinction between
doing well in school as acting white.
Rather it just
becomes part of what you do.
It doesn't have to stop in
elementary school.
They can figure out what to keep it
going.
It has to be in the DNA of the education folks
to
say, "we know; we're in this together".
See?
The job of
school is not to teach children.
The job of school is to
help grow adults.
And they can't do that by themselves
nor should they ever try.
But if they say, "well, my job
is to teach."
You got it wrong from the get-go.
You say,
"our job is to help grow adults."
And by the way, what
kind of adults do we want?
Listen.
Don't give up.
[chuckling]
Okay.
Come on up.
So I mean I think.
There's a way to
get around it but it is a real problem.
Yes, sir?
>> Male #4: Yeah, so I was wondering what
were your thoughts on
studio schools -- thoughts and feelings.
And second, it
seems like you really want to evaluate students
on a
scalable manner so be able to test them quickly
and
efficiently.
But your idea of wanting to evaluate each
kid on like what their intelligence is seems
like a case
by case evaluation basis.
Do you think -- do we have to
break that idea of wanting to scale testing?
Do we actually have to have good teaching?
How do you
balance those two?
>>John Merrow: Oh, wow -- you have to tell
me about studio schools.
>> Male #4: Sorry.
So there was a Ted talk about studio schools
schools where work is very project based.
They're
running pilot programs in London.
Somewhere in England.
Yeah.
>> John Merrow: So can I tell you talk about
project based learning
instead?
Yeah.
I wholeheartedly endorse that as a
concept.
I mean, that's really what should be going
on.
But it goes back to, journalism school where
you're
producing a newspaper or magazine or radio
show.
That's
project-based learning.
When you're in drama and you're
doing a play.
It's the kind of stuff that keeps kids in
school when they get to do things like that.
I think we
need much more of that.
We need -- my quarrel with
things like the Khan Academy which in many
ways is
terrific, my quarrel is it's isolating and
it's
acquisition of knowledge.
Which is important but you
need to go beyond that where you use that
knowledge to
create more knowledge.
And where you work with other
people.
So the more project-based learning the better.
In terms of scalability of testing, I think
you need
both.
You need something like our National Assessment
of
Educational Progress which by the way samples.
Doesn't
test every kid.
Samples the health of a district or the health
of a
school and is reliable.
But what you want is if you're
trusting teachers and the teacher is saying
'how are you
intelligent how could we build on that'?
Then there's
much more attention to you and there's much
more trust of
what I, as your teacher, say about how.
And there's some
work that you've done because it's real work.
It's more
complicated.
It's more expensive than 20 bucks.
Yeah.
I think I'm going over time here and I don't
want to keep
you from, but I do very much appreciate the
opportunity
to talk about what I've been doing for 35
years now and
hopefully for a few more years anyway.
Thank you very
much.
>>Male Presenter: Thank-you very much, John.
[Applause]